lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
encontrar el área en esta región que
estoy coloreando de amarillo y lo que
puede resultar un tanto desafiante es
que a lo largo de esta región tenemos
una función baja que sostiene el límite
inferior para ye igual a x cuadrada
sobre cuatro menos uno pero también
tenemos un límite superior que es
diferente y la forma en cómo podríamos
abordar esto es dividiendo esta área en
dos secciones o dividiendo esta región
en dos regiones que será la de la
izquierda y la derecha donde para esta
primera región de hecho la vamos a
colorear un poquito más fuerte para
dicha primera región esta se encontrará
entre 0 y 1 y veamos que cuando x es
igual a 1 dicha función es igual a 1 y
por otro lado también acá arriba si es
igual a 1 dicha función es 1 por lo que
este punto será el 11 donde se
intersecta y para esta región la función
superior sería de allí igual a la raíz
de x que tenemos a lo largo de esta
región y luego podemos establecer
diferente
o abordarlo separadamente y figurarnos
el área de esta otra región que se
encuentra de x igual a 1 a x igual a 2
donde la función igual a 2 - x es su
función superior así que hagámoslo
pensemos que esta primera región estará
definida por la integral que va desde 0
a 1 de la función raíz de x que su
función superior y luego le vamos a
restar su función inferior que en este
caso sería la de x cuadrada menos equis
cuadradas sobre cuatro menos uno y por
supuesto todo esto de x de x y bien esto
de por aquí está describiendo el área
amarilla pues puedes imaginarte la como
la diferencia de dos funciones que
esencialmente es esta altura que estoy
haciendo con diferente color
esencialmente de su altura y luego si
multiplicamos por x tenemos un pequeño
rectángulo con dicha equis y luego si lo
hacemos esto para cada una de las dichas
x tendremos diferentes rectángulos
y luego aparte de todos ellos los
tomamos y les calculamos el límite
cuando x está aproximando a 0 así
todavía para los otros rectángulos
estaríamos obteniendo un número infinito
y esto es lo que pasa con la definición
cuando hacemos la definición formal que
nos describe lo que pasa con una
integral y así es como se calcula esta
primera región ahora con la misma lógica
exacta podemos figurar nos el área de la
región derecha y con esto luego podemos
simplemente resolver las juntas o
calcular las al mismo tiempo entonces la
región de la derecha va de x igual a 1 a
2 por lo que así defino mi integral para
la función superior que es 2 menos x y a
ésta le vamos a restar la función
inferior que es x cuadrada sobre 4 menos
uno ahora simplemente tenemos que
evaluar pero primero veamos si podemos
simplificar todo esto de por aquí
esta es la integral de 0 a 1 de la raíz
de x menos aplicando el signo menos x
cuadra sobre 4
por supuesto de equis y luego más la
función de la segunda parte de la región
entonces ya la integral de 1 a 2 de 2 -
x menos equis cuadradas sobre 4 - x
menos 1 nos da más uno más el 2 que
tenemos por la caf ahora se nos
convierte esto en 3 simplemente estoy
calculando todo esto está afectando en
el signo menos entonces nos queda más 1
y más dos es más 3 y ahora sí calculando
la integral de esto que tenemos por aquí
esto es lo mismo que tener x a la un
medio y si le sumamos 1 al exponente
tenemos x a las tres medios sobre tres
medios que es lo mismo que multiplicar
por el recíproco que sería por dos
tercios menos tenemos x al cuadrado
sobre 4 que es lo mismo que hacer x
kubrick a sobre 4 por 3 sería 12
la integral de 1 que es x y todo esto
evaluado de 0 a 1 ahora más la integral
de 3 que es 3x - x cuadrada sobre 2 - x
cúbica que es la misma que la pasada
sobre 12 y todo esto evaluado de 1 a 2
todo esto evaluado de 1 a 2 y ahora sí
evaluando en dichos límites tenemos lo
siguiente aquí evaluando en 1 primero
tenemos dos tercios menos un doceavo más
uno menos todo esto evaluado en cero
pero se convierte en cero entonces le
vamos a restar nada en esta ocasión y
ahora con el siguiente color vamos a
evaluar nuestra segunda nuestro segundo
nuestra segunda integral y tendríamos
más evaluado en dos sería 6 menos 2 al
cuadrado sobre 4 es 2 menos dos al cubo
es 8 sobre 12 y en este caso si restamos
lo que evaluamos en 1 que sería
por x cuando x está evaluado en 1 de
estrés menos un medio menos un doceavo
ahora esencialmente con todo esto solo
solo hay que resolver un bonche de
fracciones donde claramente en esta
primera
el común denominador es 12 por lo tanto
tenemos 8 12 ambos menos un 2,12
doceavos por lo que al resolver esto nos
quedamos simplemente con 19 12 a vos
y esta es la parte que tenemos en
amarillo luego esto de por acá déjame lo
resuelvo y entonces tendríamos seis
menos dos es cuatro
para empezar por lo que esto es igual a
48 doceavos para el primer término luego
tenemos menos 8 doceavos y afectamos
este menos para los demás tenemos menos
36 doceavos menos por menos es más
tenemos más 6 doceavos y otra vez más
un doceavo y ahora si todo esto lo vamos
a simplificar tenemos que el 48 menos 8
es 40 menos 36 64 más 6 es igual a 10
más uno es igual a 11 por lo que
simplemente nos quedan 11 doceavos
veámoslo otra vez es 48 menos 8 pues
todos están sobre doceavos menos 36 esto
nos va a dar igual a 46 es 10 más 1 es
11 doceavos entonces tenemos todo esto
listo y al hacer la operación son
simplemente son 30 doceavos o que es lo
mismo tener y todo esto lo dividimos
entre 6 tenemos cinco medios que es lo
mismo que tener dos por un medio y lo
hemos hecho esta área que tenemos por
aquí va a ser igual o nos dio dos por un
medio